some of the questions that we got online
as we're prepared for this a lot of
people want to know what's up with the
heavy allocation of farmland you talked
about it a little bit earlier maybe go
into a little bit more detail just when
you talk about farmland kind of how do
you think about good investments there
versus bad investments and and also
through market cycles just holding the
same allocation of the farmland where
does that change over time for online
stuff you know it's an asset class it's
one of the few that's not well
represented in the global market
portfolio because the vast majority of
that worldwide historically has been in
individuals or massive institutions like
Nuveen or craft that owned just these
enormous farms there's not a whole lot
of middle ground and it's been hard for
most investors to allocate to so today
if you wanted to go get a farmland
allocation you got to either go buy a
farm and then manage it which is a
nightmare
by the way thankfully we have a lot of
friends and family in the area that can
help out too as you could invest in a
private fund that does it we've had a
few of those on the podcast to talk
about it there's some platforms that are
coming out and make it a little easier
if I was a young entrepreneur not doing
what I do now and the etf business you
know we would probably go and launch a
public REIT there's only like one or two
that do it that would give access to it
so it's hard it's a great diversifying
investment like a lot of investments are
just non-correlated if you got a
blueberry farm and over again or a wheat
farm in Kansas or an almond farm in
California or [ __ ] like those things
don't traditionally correlate directly
to what's going on the rest markets
which is what you want and then you have
of course the the private benefit which
is I put a picture on Twitter the other
day of me walking through wheat farm it
says look I'm trying to be this today it
hasn't traded and forever like I have no
idea I couldn't sell it if I wanted to
so like for a lot of people for me it's
farmland I don't own a house but for a
lot of people their biggest illiquid
investments are house right they
probably maybe with Zillow can come up
with a little more today valuations but
they can't sell it tonight it's not
something they would if they wanted to
it's a lifelong investment
but it's a big part of people's wealth
and so one of the reasons people across
the country in the world have become so
rich and wealthy with real estate
investing is because it's money they
would have spent otherwise you know
you're putting money into real estate
like it's it's getting invested the same
way with stocks we're also probably but
if it's personal for me you know I mean
it's it's a connection to my family and
my history would I be investing in it
had I not that had not that probably not
I mean I would be attracted to it
there's a lot of asset classes I'm
attracted to that I think are
interesting but certainly wouldn't be
such a large allocation plus you can go
out shake sessions and hide out the
world and we drive around on ATVs and
horses and everything else you're
talking to a guy who also grew up in
North Carolina so those are all fond
memories for me as well